[Musica]
quello che voglio provare a fare oggi
con voi è un piccolo dialogo senza
pretese da studentessa delle
potenzialità della tecnologia e
dell'apprendimento come si possono
combinare insieme allora l'evento
rivolta degli studenti quindi io direi
di iniziare con un paio di domande
potete alzare la mano anzi dovete alzare
la mano quanti di voi pensano che il
divieto di utilizzare i propri cellulari
a scuola sia in qualche modo limitante e
quante persone quanti ragazzi hanno mai
sentito parlare di questa sigla di wilde
è un acronimo inglese ma qualcuno allora
l'acronimo inglese be wired di busta per
bring your own device ed ero un
approccio aziendale che prevede appunto
l'utilizzo del proprio dispositivo
all'interno del luogo di lavoro pensate
che il 95 per cento delle aziende
utilizza questo sistema a livello
mondiale
quindi se lo fanno in così tanti un
motivo ci sarà e la scuola in quanto un
po palestra per le nostre future
carriere potrebbe della respirazione
però non tutti la pensano così in
francia è stata appena approvato una
legge che vieta ai ragazzi di ogni
ordine e grado di utilizzare il proprio
telefono cellulare
anche durante le pause perché perché si
pensa che i ragazzi smettano e
socializzare
allora io non sono d'accordo dopo un
anno e mezzo di lock down with you are
called dei menu di prenotazioni digitali
ma è ovvio che la tecnologia del
digitale è diventata la parte integrante
della nostra vita e lo sarà sempre di
più
credo anche che tra l'associazione e il
divieto completo esista uno spettro ci
siamo dimenticati che alle volte si sono
gli spettri spettri di possibilità
infinite costruttive possibilità sane e
poi pensa un'altra cosa che questa
generazione di giovani e sias ki won sia
stimata un po poco dovrebbe essere
stimato un po di più pensate che questo
evento è stato realizzato soltanto da
dei ragazzi
due anni ma sono ragazzi ancora più
giovani di me
tornando al tema del lavoro il rischio
principale se non si sviluppano le
giuste competenze tecnologiche e questo
qui il mismatch c'è il disallineamento
tra la domanda e l'offerta di lavoro
se invece lo guardiamo dal punto di
vista della scuola sentiamo parlare
molto di questa altra sigla stefan che
sta per science technology ingegneria
matematica che sono le materie
scientifiche che possiamo chiamare
questo senza però dimenticarsi di quello
che è stato il pilastro fondamentale
dello sviluppo della nostra civiltà
europea della nostra cultura italiana
cioè discipline umanistiche quelle viene
chiamato il trivio le letterature le
arti la filosofia
beh allora come potremmo fare per
sviluppare nei ragazzi le giuste
competenze tecnologiche potenziare le
materie stem anche quando si parla di
parità di genere nel mondo del lavoro e
tutelare le discipline umanistiche
secondo me un modo per farlo è questo
appunto in digitale
vediamo come funziona un po la scuola ne
hanno parlato i miei precedenti relatori
che sono stati bravissimi io non sono
all'altezza però adesso proverò a
spiegarlo è l'approccio maggiormente
diffuso negli istituti scolastici
universitari italiani è questo
l'approccio comportamentista dove il
ragazzo impara da quello che vede
dall'altra parte dell'aula non solo
dall'altra parte ma le cattedre sono
anche sopraelevate per un motivo e ciò
che sviluppa sono delle arti e delle
attività cognitive passive dove
sicuramente il bagaglio di informazioni
che viene recepito è molto ampio ma si
dimentica anche molto facilmente molto
velocemente sempre di più realtà si sta
sviluppando quest'altro approccio che è
quello costruttivista dove si cerca di
creare dei modelli mentali nelle teste
dei ragazzi affinché siano loro a capire
effettivamente quello quello che la
nozione quindi non è più un sistema
basato sul premiare le risposte giuste e
penalizzare quelle negative che è un po
lo specchio delle grandi teorie
psicologiche del novecento ma è un
premiare il percorso costante che ha
portato all'obiettivo allora io sono
appena tornata dal cammino di santiago
de compostela
perché se ne parla come una di quelle
esperienze che ti cambia la vita perché
fra le altre cose fa sentire il
pellegrino sempre coinvolto e
gratificato di quello che sta facendo
ogni giorno mi alzavo e camminando
dovevo collezionare almeno due timbri
lungo il percorso fino ad arrivare alla
tomba dell'apostolo giacomo dove ho
ricevuto un certificato che si chiama
compostela che è una pergamena e questo
secondo me è un esempio perfetto perché
la scuola
secondo me dovrebbe essere un po così
dovrebbe essere
premiare il percorso costante che si fa
perché ogni pellegrino alla fine con più
un percorso diverso però la via tutti
appunto ricevono questo certificato e
questa è la mia idea di scuola non tanto
la valutazione di una performance
istantanea di quello che può essere un
test a crocette e come dicevo prima alle
volte ci sono delle facilitazioni il
digitale può essere una di queste
ho provato a fare a cercare degli esempi
pratici allora molti di voi avranno
avuto a che fare con un libro di scienze
libro di scienze con una
rappresentazione bidimensionale di una
cellula umana e alle volte una
rappresentazione poco realistica e di
difficile comprensione anche perché ha
un occhio esperto anche per gli stessi
professori mi è capitato più volte di di
sentirli
e pensate se vicino a l'immagine
bidimensionale ci fosse un più hardcore
che inquadrato con il proprio telefono
mostrasse la rappresentazione
tridimensionale e foto realistica di
quella che è veramente una cellula ma un
opzione sarebbe quindi l'introduzione
della realtà aumentata una cosa che può
sembrare così in realtà è molto più
simile a questo quindi inquadrando
accordi in questo caso abbiamo un divano
ma potrebbe essere la nostra cellula
questo potrebbe essere un esempio banale
di un metodo riformista e non
rivoluzionario che può apportare il
digitale all'interno della didattica
all'interno dei libri senza andare a
demolire quella che è stata la colonna
portante dell'apprendimento
fino ad ora cioè il cartaceo libro
cartaceo quindi per esempio si
potrebbero sviluppare dei percorsi che
possono portare gli stessi ragazzi a
creare i loro chi barcode per
visualizzare il sistema solare una
molecola di dinosauri questi sono gli
esempi molto banale
in più se consideriamo la famigerata
dalla didattica a distanza potrebbero
essere dei metodi per un po militare
quello che si è perso cioè l'engagement
fra i docenti gli alunni e i corsi
un'importante università americana nel
2018 appunto studiato l'impatto della
tecnologia all'interno del sistema
scolastico
i risultati parlano chiaro perché perché
se il digitale viene affiancato alla
giusta formazione rivolta a
i docenti si riesce a fare questo potere
di simulazione c'è da spiegare i
fenomeni naturali grazie alla tecnologia
in modo intuitivo in modo semplice e
questo vale anche e soprattutto per
l'insegnamento delle lingue che siano
degli idiomi o che siano i linguaggi di
programmazione il cui insegnamento
diventerà appunto obbligatorio nelle
scuole italiane di ogni ordine e grado a
partire dal prossimo anno
però quando si parla di education che il
tema di questo ted non c'è soltanto da
scuola e qui vi chiedo di fare un salto
indietro allora marzo 2020 lockdown
totale in italia
a me ma spero anche ad alcuni di voi è
capitato spesso di ricevere nelle chat
per passare il tempo
molti link per fare questo i virtual
tour dei musei dei grandi musei
marchiati all'agi internazionale la
tecnologia per le istituzioni culturali
è fondamentale per due motivi
principalmente in primis per la
definizione stessa di tecnologia quindi
per rendere la ricerca la conservazione
sempre più precisa facile e accurato e
poi per il vantaggio competitivo la leva
di vantaggio competitivo in economia è
ciò che mi permette di essere migliore
degli altri per diversi motivi in questo
caso perché posso creare dei tour delle
esperienze diverse unica finalmente
nuovi modi per mantenermi come museo dal
punto di vista economico altrimenti
purtroppo non le istituzioni culturali
sono molto delicate molto pagine e qui
entra in gioco un altro strumento sempre
più diffuso che è la realtà virtuale
questo penso che sia appunto molto più
noto e irrisori di realtà virtuale penso
che le abbiate visti tutti si pensa sia
materiale da videogiocatore non è così
saranno sempre più utili in futuro
perché i grandi gruppi editoriali i
governi 6 ingaggiano le aziende di
hardware e software quando a sviluppare
scenari di ricostruzione artificiali
praticamente con potenzialità infinita
pensate che i primi musei virtuali in
italia sono aperti da più di dieci anni
che quello che quindi quello che può
sembrare fantascienza non è nient'altro
che la realtà è però è pur vero un'altra
cosa io ha detto michele penzo non lo so
sono sto prendendo una laurea ho preso
una laurea vediamola come volete in
management culturale è una cosa nota c'è
una polarizzazione per molti il museo è
ancora un'entità pura qualcosa che non
può cambiare
dall'altro lato però
i visori sono divertenti ve lo assicuro
e permettono quello che dicevo prima
cioè di fare di creare dei tour
personalizzati e come il suo arco di
prima senza andare intaccare quello che
c'è sempre stato il museo tradizionale
nessuno andrà ad abbattere il museo
tradizionale permettere un visore di
realtà virtuale ma le due cose possono
possono essere perfettamente
complementari
ecco per esempio fare beni tour
diversificati per farci una grafia un
nome marketing si chiama segmentazione e
questa cosa è molto efficace però
quell'istituto delle istituzioni
culturali ancora di più allora sapete
come si calcolano le entrate di cassa
dell'istituzione culturale la regola che
mi è stata insegnata e la cosiddetta
regola dei terzi quindi un terzo dalla
cassa dal numero di biglietti venduti
un terzo dagli sponsor quindi dai
privati per esempio le banche è un terzo
dei fondi pubblici
questa è una regola di equilibrio non
sto parlando di profitti
pensate quanto potrebbe essere ampia una
partnership tra lo sponsor che è
l'azienda che sviluppa hardware e
software con applicazione culturale e il
piccolo e grande museo italiano che
cerca nuovi modi per mantenersi e vi
assicuro che cercano nuovi modi per
mantenerci
quindi quando si parla di cultura che
sia una scuola che sia un cinema che sia
un museo teatro
una cosa è certa la fragilità di questi
enti così importanti perché sono enti
che portano con loro il fardello di
essere la rappresentazione della nostra
cultura in quanto cittadini italiani
cittadini europei e cittadini del mondo
ma anche di dover trasmettere questa
nostra identità alle nuove generazioni
che la cosa più difficile la fa quindi
tre cose sono fondamentali secondo me
quando si parla di cultura emozioni
esperienze e bellezza perché inutile che
ve lo dico a l'italia al record per i
siti dell'unesco perché è un paese
bellissimo e quindi non dobbiamo mai
dimenticarci questo innamorarci della
bellezza di quello che ci fa sentire
veramente vivi
poi quello che diceva anche virginia
prima con la speranza però che la
tecnologia che qui dirò una banalità poi
vista come uno strumento e non come
diciamo il fulcro da cui partire di 20 e
in qualche modo la spalla di questa di
tutta questa bellezza grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]